[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland und zu einer neuen Folge der
wir eine trägerwarnung voranstellen
müssen in der heutigen Ausgabe geht es
um extrem brutale Morde aus sexuellen
Motiven und darüber hinaus um sehr
verstörende fälle von Tierquälerei und
Nekrophilie wem solche Schilderungen zu
nahe gehen der sollte sich diese Folge
bitte nicht anhören
in der heutigen Folge geht es um einen
Mann der als der
rhein-ruhr-ripper bezeichnet wurde weil
seine Taten viele an Jack the Ripper
Inhalt haben mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir
und ich erzähle die Geschichte zusammen
mit meiner wunderbaren podcast-partnerin
Toni Hayer hallo Toni hallo Mirko und
hallo ihr da draußen Mirko hat es schon
gesagt unser heutiger Fall ist verdammt
grausam aber wir werden uns bemühen ihn
halbwegs sachlich darzustellen und wir
werden hier nicht in aller
Ausführlichkeit die grausigsten Details
der Taten ausbreiten es wird auch so
schon schlimm genug ja ich finde es
sowieso immer eine schwierige Abwägung
wie explizit man in einem true
crime-format mit der Darstellung von
Gewalt umgeht manchmal kann man auf die
grausigen Details verzichten oder sie
abgeschwächt wiedergeben eine anderen
Fällen und das sind dann die Ausgaben
mit deiner triggerwarnung kommt man aber
nicht umhin auch diese zu erzählen
vielleicht fangen wir erstmal von vorne
an und erzähl die Geschichte von Frank
Gust Frank Gust wird 1969 in Oberhausen
geboren
wenige Monate nach seiner Geburt reicht
die Mutter die Scheidung ein der Vater
trinkt und vernachlässigt die Familie da
sie selbst voll berufstätig ist kümmert
sich die Oma um Frank und seinen älteren
Bruder doch bald darauf erkrankt die
Großmutter und er wird bis auf die
Sonntage die er bei seiner Mutter
verbringt in einem Säuglingsheim betreut
okay moment mal vielleicht machen wir
hier gleich noch mal ganz kurz Stopp
vieles was wir über die Kindheit und
Jugend von Frank Gust erzählen werden
das klingt ein bisschen nach einer
Checkliste für Serienmörder
zum Beispiel schon die frühe Trennung
von der Mutter das weggeben ins Heim die
schrecklichen Sachen die er erleben wird
und die schrecklichen Sachen die
ertieren antun wird da kommt man leicht
an dem Punkt wo man wissen mit dem Kopf
nickt und sich denkt ja ist ja völlig
klar wie das ausgeht ja das mag sein
aber natürlich gibt es keinen
Automatismus und keine Formel also
schlimme Kindheit gleich zukünftiger
Psychopath wir sprechen von Faktoren die
möglicherweise einen bestimmten
Lebensweg begünstigen können und von
möglichen Warenzeichen aber nicht von
zwangsläufigen und allgemeingültigen
Entwicklungen wer als Kind Zurückweisung
und körperliche und seelische Gewalt
erdulden muss der ist vor allem erst
einmal Opfer und benötigt Hilfe und
Verständnis
und nur in sehr sehr sehr wenigen
Ausnahmefällen werden diese Opfer später
zu einem Täter wie Frank Gust aber Mirko
erzähl mal weiter später so um die Zeit
als Frank Gust im Kindergartenalter ist
zieht die Familie in ein kleines Haus
die Oma die Mutter der ältere Bruder und
er Frank ist ein einzelgängerisches Kind
das keine Freunde findet und schon früh
gemobbt wird und missbraucht außerhalb
der Familie mehrfach so berichtet er
selbst viele Jahre später
1977 heiratet die Mutter erneut einen
Polizisten der ein strenges Regiment
einführt er ist nicht der liebevolle
Ersatzvater den Frank gebraucht hätte
die Großmutter seine wichtigste
Bezugsperson zieht in Folge der Hochzeit
aus dem Haus der Familie aus
Frank Gust wird mit 8 Jahren wieder zum
Bettnässer ihr beginnt in Geschäften
Dinge zu stehlen und entwickelt sich zu
einem gewohnheitsmäßigen Lügner der
Stiefvater der Polizist durchsucht in
regelmäßig und es gibt gruselige
Berichte nach denen sich das Kind für
diese Durchsuchungen wie ein Verbrecher
im Film mit abgespreizten Armen und
Beinen an die Wand stellen musste findet
der Stiefvater etwas das wie ein Fehler
wirkt oder ihm nicht passt dann wird das
Kind streng bestraft mit neun Jahren hat
er einen Erlebnis dass ihn beeindruckt
und prägt er hat eine Mitschüler ein
Meerschweinchen abgekauft da er weiß
dass er es auf keinen Fall zu Hause
halten kann bringt er es zu seiner
Großmutter doch auch die sagt ihm dass
er das Tier nicht behalten können er
solle es zurückgeben
als er erklärt dass das nicht ginge da
sagt sie ihm dass er es dann eben töten
müsse also bindet ihr das kleine Tier an
Stöcken fest die er in die Erde gerammt
hat er will es mit einer Betonplatte
erschlagen es soll nicht leiden ganz
schnell soll es gehen doch er verfehlt
den Kopf die Platte trifft den Bauch des
Meerschweinchens und die gedärmequellen
heraus
okay die meisten von uns hätte dieser
Anblick wohl schockiert und geekelt
der kleine Frank Gust aber genießt den
Anblick und der beginnt in der
Bauchhöhle herumzuwühlen und die Wärme
das soeben getöteten Körpers zu genießen
in den folgenden Jahren wird er zum
obsessiven Tierquäler er steht Kaninchen
in der Nachbarschaft quält und tötet sie
als er in die Pubertät kommt verbindet
sich sein Sexualtrieb mit dieser Lust am
quälen und töten mit 12 lässt er sich
selbst ins Heim einweisen um der Familie
zu entkommen als er 13 ist schleicht er
sich bei einem Krankenhausaufenthalt in
die Pathologie und sieht dort seine
erste Leiche
von da an beginnt er auf Friedhöfen und
in Leichenhallen die Körper verstorbener
aufzuschlitzen und sich dabei sexuell zu
befriedigen doch die große Befriedigung
stellt sich nicht ein die Körper sind
kalt ihm fehlt diese Wärme der er seit
dem Erlebnis mit dem Meerschweinchen
hinterherjagt
kurzzeitig erwägt er die Leichen
aufzuwärmen verwirft diesen Gedanken
aber wieder und so tötet er weiter Tiere
immer und immer wieder Kaninchen aber
auch größere Tiere
Schafe Pferde oder Kühe
in einem Interview mit der Kriminologin
Petra Klages sagt er dabei drehte es
sich aber nicht mehr darum Sex mit den
Tieren zu haben die Körpergröße war
einfach so groß dass ich damit meine
hauptwunschvorstellung ganz in den
Körper eintauchen zu können immer näher
kam und da ging es dann eben nicht nur
ums penetrieren sondern ums komplette
eintauchen meist erschießt er die Tiere
vor allem die großen die im gefährlich
werden könnten seine Mutter ist
passionierte Jägerin und auch Frank Gust
macht als Jugendlicher einen Jagdschein
die reguläre Jagd interessiert ihn zwar
nicht besonders und das Gabe und die
Dunkel der Jäger stoßen ihn ab doch es
ist ein Weg an eine Pistole zu kommen
in seiner Fantasie ist der längst über
den Punkt hinaus wo er nur Tiere quält
er will Menschen töten er will Frauen
töten in denen er wir später aussagt wie
sie sieht und 1994 frank ist da 25 Jahre
alt da ist das so weit
sein erstes Opfer ist eine Tramperin
eine junge Frau aus Südafrika die
zurzeit in den Niederlanden lebt die die
Welt kennenlernen will und durch Europa
reist kurz zuvor hat sich Franks
damalige Freundin von ihm getrennt und
die Großmutter gibt ihm den Rat mit dem
Auto herum zu fahren um sich zu
beruhigen
Frank stimmt zu was die Oma nicht ahnt
ist das ist nicht das Autofahren ist mit
dem er sich zu beruhigen hofft im
Handschuhfach seines Wagens liegt wie
eigentlich immer seine Pistole bereit
er will einmal mehr ein Kaninchen
schießen es Ausweiden und sich sexuell
befriedigen doch dann sieht er die junge
Frau am Straßenrand sie streckt den
Daumen aus um mitgenommen zu werden
Gust lässt die Frau einsteigen sie
unterhalten sich freundlich und angeregt
während Gust überlegt ob heute der Tag
ist um seinen ultimativen Traum zu
erfüllen hat er alles dabei was er
braucht für die Tat und um hinterher die
Spuren an sich und am Wagen zu
beseitigen
er stoppt den Wagen angeblich muss er
kurz austreten dann will er den Wagen
Schlüssel verloren haben die arglose
Tramperin hilft ihm suchen
Frank Gust erschießt sie von hinten
dann vergeht er sich an der Leiche und
trennt ihr anschließend die Hände und
den Kopf ab um eine Identifizierung
schwerer zu machen er packt sie in den
Kofferraum fährt über die Grenze in die
Niederlande und legt sie am Straßenrand
ab
Frank Gust hat seinen ersten Mord
begangen doch es ist nicht die Erfüllung
des ultimativen Traumes der Mord wird
nicht aufgeklärt obwohl niederländische
und deutsche Behörden zusammenarbeiten
obwohl man DNA-Spuren des Täters an der
Leiche findet und trotz zahlreicher
Hinweise die nach einer Ausgabe von
Aktenzeichen XY ungelöst Eintreffen der
Täter lebt ein scheinbar normales Leben
er arbeitet er verliebt sich er heiratet
er wird glücklicher Vater für eine kurze
Zeit scheint die Normalität und
Geborgenheit der Familie über seine
dunklen Seiten zu triumphieren doch
gleichzeitig ist da die ganze Zeit über
dieser Keller den seine Frau unter
keinen Umständen betreten darf denn das
dunkle das ist immer da
es versteckt sich nur hinter der
Kellertür
dorthin zieht sich Francos zurück um
sich mit seinen Kaninchen dort zu
beschäftigen und 1996 zwei Jahre nach
dem ersten Mord bricht es mit voller
Brutalität wieder hervor
auf dem Straßenstrich in Essen nimmt er
eine Prostituierte mit er erschießt sie
während er mit ihr schläft dann weidet
er sie aus trennt wieder Hände und Kopf
ab und drapiert ihre Leiche regelrecht
an einem Straßenrand
dieser Mord ist wirklich verdammt dicht
dran an meiner ultimativen
Wunschvorstellung erklärt er später dem
Regensburger psychiatrieprofessor
Michael osterheider wir haben eine Sache
ausgelassen bereits vor dem zweiten Mord
hat er seiner Mutter später auch seine
Ehefrau erzählt dass er eine Tramperin
getötet habe seine Mutter glaubt ihm
nicht seiner Frau sagt er dass er nur
ein liebes- und loyalitätstest gewesen
beide gehen nicht zur Polizei selbst der
Ex-Mann der Mutter der Polizist der ihm
in seiner Kindheit so zugesetzt hat hält
das alles für Quatsch
der Junge habe schon immer eine lebhafte
Fantasie gehabt ich kann es mir nur so
erklären wenn dein Sohn oder dein Mann
also jemand den du liebst und von dem du
wirklich glaubst ihn zu kennen die etwas
so schreckliches beichtet dann kannst du
es einfach nicht glauben dann wehrt sich
alles in der dagegen sowas darf nicht
wahr sein
liebe macht blind das sagt man ja immer
wieder und ich glaube das stimmt ein
Stück weit weil man kennt ja auch die
guten die liebevollen oder ja allgemein
die positiven Seiten dieses Menschen und
das wäre so eine düstere grausame
schreckliche Seite an sich hat ich
glaube das kann man sich nicht
vorstellen
die Mutter wird später in Interviews und
Briefen beschreiben wie schuldig Sie
sich deshalb fühlt und das eigentlich
sie im Gefängnis sitzen sollte diese
Schuldgefühle müssen sie schrecklich
quälen das ist eine Sache die man bei
solchen Taten schnell vergisst das so
viel mehr Leben zerstört oder beschädigt
werden als die Kriminalstatistik zählt
es gibt noch jemanden dem sich Frank
Gust anvertraut eine Tante seiner
Ehefrau und sie scheint ihre Augen nicht
verschließen zu wollen als sie droht ihn
anzuzeigen tötet er die 47-Jährige
vor Gericht stellt er die Sache anders
da die Tante habe sterben wollen er habe
ihr beim Suizid geholfen
die Ermittler gehen jedoch davon aus
dass es sich um einen vertuschungsmord
handelt die Leiche zerstückelt er und
verstreut sie in einem Wald
1998 tötet er erneut seine Prostituierte
es ist sein letzter und schrecklichster
Mord es geht ihm nicht mehr vor allem
ums töten er will sein Opfer leiden
sehen
stundenlang foltert er die Frau bevor er
sie endlich erschießt seine Fantasien
werden immer grausiger die Grenzen
seiner ultimativen Wunschvorstellung die
werden immer weiter hinausgeschoben
jetzt möchte er eine Frau sprengen Gust
kauft ein Schaf in der Nähe einer
einsamen Hütte im Wald fesselt er das
Tier und präpariert es mit zwei
Sprengladungen
in seiner Fantasie liegt dort kein Schaf
vor ihm sondern eine Frau er redet mit
dem Schaf als sei es eine Frau und
erklärt ihm dass er es jetzt bei vollem
Bewusstsein springen werde
dieselben Sätze die er eines Tages einem
Menschen sagen will dann geht Gust
hinter die Hütte und zündet die
Sprengsätze
zum Glück wird Frank Gust diese perverse
Ideen nicht mehr in die Tat umsetzen
1999 erzählt seine Mutter einer
Bekannten von Franks fünf Jahre
zurückliegenden mordgeständen ist und
die geht endlich zur Polizei Frank Gust
besteht umgehend die Morde zwar zieht er
dieses Geständnis kurz darauf wieder
zurück aber ein Vergleich seiner DNA mit
denen am ersten Opfer gefundenen Spuren
überführt ihn er gesteht erneut
umfangreich in allen Details aber er hat
eine Bedingung seine Frau soll beim
Geständnis dabei sein das finde ich
richtig schlimm die Frau die ihn geliebt
hat für die er Ehemann und liebender
Vater des gemeinsamen Kindes war und die
wirklich glaubte er habe mit seiner
früheren Mordgeschichte nur ihre
Loyalität testen wollen die muss ich
jetzt in allen Einzelheiten anhören wie
er vier Frauen darunter ihre eigene
Tante bestialisch ermordet hat am 21
Dezember 2000 wird er vom Duisburger
Schwurgericht wegen vierfachen Todes zu
lebenslanger Haft verurteilt das Gericht
stellt eine verminderte Schuldfähigkeit
fest an das Urteil ist die
auflagegebunden sich einer Therapie zu
unterziehen
doch Gust bricht diese bereits nach
wenigen Monaten wieder ab er hält sich
nicht für therapierbar gegenüber dem
Psychiater osterheider äußert er der
feste Villa das was ich getan habe nicht
wieder zu tun ist bei mir nicht
vorhanden meine perversen Fantasien sind
nach wie vor da
francoste bitte darum nie wieder
freigelassen zu werden
[Musik]
die Geschichte des Serienmörders Frank
Gust haben wir unter anderem anhand des
Artikels ein nützlicher Mörder im
spiegelausgabe 34
2005 erzählt weitere Quellen waren ein
Interview der Kriminologin Petra Klages
mit dem Täter selbst veröffentlicht auf
Petra minus klages.de ein Artikel der
Welt mit dem Titel mein Sohn ist ein
Mörder eine Ausgabe der Serie mordorte
von WDR Lokalzeit und die Wikipedia bis
zum nächsten mal euer Mirko und eure tun